hello and welcome i'm james murphy from
m coding
and today we're talking about the single
most
important feature coming soon in python
3.10
i'm talking about structural pattern
matching and the match
statement depending on when you're
watching this video python 3.10 might
already be out
but at the time of recording which is
march 17
2021 python 3.9 is the latest version
i just saw that pep634 on structural
pattern matching was accepted so i had
to
download my own copy of the latest
branch of python
compile it and try running it for myself
as you can see down here in my python
console
i am running a version of python 3.10
you can see here the exact git commit
hash
of the commit that i'm using so i
couldn't wait to check out this new
feature i had to just compile it myself
and i thought i'd make a video about it
so here it is
basically in prior versions of python we
already had some very primitive
versions of pattern matching so if i
have for example
x comma y i can say x comma y is equal
to one comma two
now what does this mean well python is
smart enough to figure out that
well this is a sequence of length 2 and
this looks like a sequence of length 2
so it figures out to assign x to 1 and y
to 2.
this new syntax through the match
statement takes it to a whole new level
let's take a look at some examples so
all throughout this video
you can look on your left to see the new
syntax
and on the right how you would have to
write it or what might be the simplest
way to write it
without using the match statement so of
course python is determined complete
language
the match statement doesn't really add
anything
new in terms of what programs can be
written what it adds is
a new way to think about programs so on
the left is going to be the new match
syntax and on the right is going to be
the old way of doing it first up we have
this function command split
which takes in a command which is let's
say a string
we'll do a command split and that will
break up the string into a list of
strings
and then we want to do different things
based off of what those things are so
you can imagine
this would be useful if you're like
writing a shell just for demonstration
purposes i have a few different commands
here
so you can see we're going to match what
does
this command dot split look like and
then the syntax is you have a match
and then the thing that you want to
match and then a bunch of cases
that it could look like so the way that
it works is python will compute this
and then try each case one after another
until it finds a match
if it doesn't find a match it's kind of
like an if false where it just wouldn't
execute anything in the body
this is similar to a switch statement
but on steroids so you can see that on
the left we have a much more declarative
style than on the right
well first off the code on the right is
terrible i mean
can anyone look at this and just read
what it's doing
probably not you have to go through
every single one and check
you know is the length two and the first
one zero you have to really read every
single line
whereas on the left it's a much more
declarative style where you just say
this is what it looks like does it match
so let's just slowly go through a few
different cases and then you'll sort of
get the idea of how the match statement
works
so in this first case we're matching
a list with one element whose only thing
in it is the word make
that's pretty self-explanatory now
technically speaking when you do a match
like this
it doesn't have to be a list that you're
matching against it can be any sequence
type so if i passed in a tuple
it would still match a list in the
second case
we're saying we have a sequence of two
elements the first of which is make
and then we just put in the name of a
variable here similar to the way a for
loop works
this cmd does not have to be already
defined
this is a name and we are binding
whatever value is in the sequence at
that point to this name
now if you read the documentation it is
very careful to always use the word
bind rather than a sign which you might
you know colloquially think of we're
going to assign the value here
to the variable cmd but for technical
reasons
it is not actually assigning the next
case is just another
single element restart we've already
been over that
this next case is the word
rm remove followed by any number
of extra arguments so this is similar to
a star args
situation here where there can be zero
or more things here
and this files variable will then be
a tuple containing all of those
extra things so you can see on the right
hand side what it's actually doing
it's going to be checking if the length
is right if it sees the rm
and then assigning or technically not
assigning but i'm going to slip up and
use that word
it's going to be assigning files to
whatever is left
and then finally this underscore is the
python way of saying a wildcard anything
so case underscore will match any
pattern
so in the comparison with a switch
statement this is kind of like your
default case if nothing else matches
then this case will be executed now if i
didn't have this wildcard case here
and i passed in something that doesn't
match any of the other things then just
nothing would be printed
if it doesn't match it doesn't execute
and you can see on the right hand side
how this compares the wild card is much
like an else
so let's go ahead and just put in some
test cases to see what they do
and you know run it to prove that i
actually compiled the python
so you can see command split make we do
a make a make clean a restart remove abc
and then something that doesn't match
and you can see we do a make make clean
so we say found command clean
and then a restart and then deleting the
files
abc and so you see files was passed here
as a list and then the wildcard
statement
okay let's move on to the next example
so in the last example we were matching
on a command
dot split i just wanted to put this in
so you can see that you can actually
match on a variable itself
you don't have to match on some
sub-expression so this is just almost a
simpler example
i can match a variable against
certain specific values so in this case
it will check to see if they're equal by
using the equals equals operator
unless of course you're using true false
or none in which case they'll be
compared with the is operator
so in this case i think i might actually
prefer the old syntax
and of course if we add in a little use
case here then we can see
that it matches the 42.
okay let's move on in this example we
see that you can use the pipe operator
to give alternatives for the same case
so in this case i take in a command and
i can either say
north or go north and both of those will
have the same effect
you can even do it when you're binding a
variable even if the position of the
variable
is different from case to case so you
can see in this case i can say
get object or pick up object or pick
object up
and all of those will match notice how
simple this syntax is if i wanted to do
the exact same thing
this is what it looks like in python 3.9
say
much more complicated on this side much
easier to be read on this side
and on the right side we have code
duplication
which means a chance for error
especially if something changes in the
future
so you can see if i add these two use
cases then
both of these match in the expected way
so i said go north and pick up sword
this example is short and sweet but it
really shows off the important feature
of structural pattern matching
it's composable in any pattern
i can put another pattern as part of the
pattern
so you can see in this case i'm matching
i have a list the first element is go
and the second element is this pattern
so it can be north south east or west so
i can say go north go south go east or
go west
when i have alternatives like this i'm
not necessarily going to know
which one of that sub-pattern matched
so python also allows you to use this
add
and then the name of the variable to
capture the value of that match
you can see that with these test cases
see going north going east direction
gets first north and then east this next
example
shows off guards in match statements
so this is similar to when you have a
list comprehension
you say something for something in
something
if and then you give a condition and it
only goes through the elements where
that condition is true
so you can have a case and then say this
case only applies
if this condition holds so in this
situation you have a command which is
like telling a character which direction
to move
and then you're also passing in a list
of exits
so if there's an exit on the north but
there's a wall
on the east then you can't go to the
east you could only go to the north
something like that
so i'll say go direction but only if the
direction
is in the set of allowable directions
and if i match something which is go
and then here's the use of a wild card
go and then anything
that didn't match this then i just say
you can't go that way
so if i give these two examples go north
and go north both times but if the exits
are east and south
in the first case and the north and the
second case then we should expect that
it
is only able to go north in the second
case
and indeed when we don't have a north
exit when we say go north we get
can't go that way but when there is then
we get going north
for this next example imagine that we
have some kind of event-driven
architecture
we're receiving events and they're
getting passed to this function
and our events can be clicks they can be
key presses or it can be a quit event
now you're really going to like this one
because this massively simplifies the
code makes it
way easier to read i hope you appreciate
how nice this pattern matching is in
this instance
so i take an event and i'm matching on
the event
the match statement cases can use the
following syntax
you can put in for a case the name of a
class
and you can fill in some of its
attributes so
in this case i've filled in the
attribute button
and i've given it a value so this case
is matching
is the event an instance of the click
class so is it a click whose button
is left and then notice position x y
x and y aren't defined here so x and y
are going to be variables that get
assigned
the value of these positions you might
think that this syntax is going to
construct a click
and in any other place in python that is
what would happen but specifically
inside a match statement
next to a case just like this if you
write what looks like the constructor of
a class what you're actually saying is
match something that is an instance of
that class with those particular
attributes
so you can see this case i'll match any
left click
this will match any other click in this
case i'm matching a key press
but i'm specifying capital q or
lowercase q
as a positional argument not as a
keyword argument like here i'm saying
keyname
equals up arrow or here i'm effectively
saying keyname
is capital q or lower q if you want to
match any instance of a class you just
give it
like this with an empty constructor and
finally here this is kind of another
wildcard case
except i'm giving a name to it i'm
saying if you reach this case it will
match anything
and we'll bind the name
other event to that value now of course
i already had access to the variable
event so it's kind of pointless
to give it another name other event but
if this was some kind of asynchronous
framework i might do something like
you know event.get at which point i no
longer have access to this as a variable
so this would allow me to capture it at
that moment
but for now let's just get rid of that
so here are the test cases for that
function
we're going to do a left click as zero
zero
and then a quit and then something that
doesn't match
so you see we have a left click and then
quitting
and then we caught the exception so it
didn't match
in the other case now before we move on
i just want to point out again
look how much more readable the left
hand side is compared to the right hand
side
even though my syntax highlighting isn't
working properly on the left-hand side
for obvious reasons pycharm doesn't know
about 310 syntax
but still on the left hand side i can
easily read through
know what case is going to be matched
and what's going to happen
whereas the right hand side you really
just have to read line by line
the last thing that i want to show off
is dictionary matching so let's match on
an event
which you should be imagining that you
have some kind of web api
and you just got some json and now you
want to act on that json
based off of certain properties of it so
you say what kind of json event does
this look like
well if you have a dictionary like
object you can match it
as a dictionary you can say does this
thing have a key called transport
with value http and then you can act on
that
now it's fine if there are other keys in
the dictionary so i could have transport
http
and then some other value floating
around in there it only matches
on the things that are present in this
case
you can see that we can have multiple
keys multiple values
and what this is saying here with this
n which again is not defined this is
like the variable in a for loop
we are going to define it at that moment
it's saying
is the key page number present and
if so assign or bind its value
to the name n so let's just add in that
test case i'm going to pass in
a get request for the articles page and
i want page 5
and there is some extra info in there
which is not going to affect
the match statement and you can see let
me get that article for you
on page five so that's the match
statement
i know that they're going to be heavy
heavy debates about
where it is most appropriate to use a
match statement
you know is this good code style what is
good code style for this
you know new kind of statement there are
going to be lots of debates
on when and where it is most appropriate
to use
a match statement but i think that
at least we can take away from this
video
that in some situations a match
statement can take
totally unreadable code and make it
readable at a glance
so although i think that the match
statement it's not really necessary as a
programming language feature
i do think that it will find its place
in the python community and it will find
its use cases
so that's my take on structural pattern
matching the match statement what i
think
is going to be the single most important
new feature
introduced in python 3.10. let me know
if you find any other interesting uses
for the match statement
or even better if you think that there's
something else
new in python 3.10 which is even better
than the match statement
so i hope you enjoyed this sneak preview
of what's coming ahead
in python 3.10 if you like the video
don't forget to like comment and
subscribe
see you in the next one